hello and welcome back to game sports
continuing coverage of e3 2015 live from
the West hole right here in Los Angeles
California I'm done you are taking over
for Chris waters for a little bit and
I'm very happy to be joined by Hassan a
rock a deal my friends hey pleasure IO
Interactive it says it on the shirt hug
on you've got hit man coming back to
bias Reapers back I will never stop
calling him Tobias Reaper I don't care
how long agent 47 is pretty cool but
Tobias Reapers got a certain ring to it
and it'll trailers actually playing up
here on the sony booth behind us and
tell us about the impetus to get em hit
man back absolution obviously did pretty
well what we guys what is it a bit hit
man that I oh just love going back and
creating new games about him right i
mean now we've been doing hitman for 17
years now right so all the experiences
from the earlier games in the series
also for blood money and an absolution
yeah last game we did it's kind of you
know we just call this our new game
hitman this is just all the experience
with the hat in this game to make the
best possible hitman fantasy right yeah
um trying something new something bold
and very excited about it the delivery
method is interesting because you guys
are launching almost like a base game in
december of this year and then you're
going to be adding to it right like
Raptors it kind of suits the form of a
hitman game actually because all the
levels are always like just individual
yeah i mean it's very hip driven right
out this game is you know going back to
its roots classical hitman experience
with rich you know high-profile targets
and you know strong story about these
targets and the subplots around these
targets that's what what this is about
right and as you said you know the the
experience going to stop the december
the eighth from there on we're gonna
just you know grow grow the grow the
world of assassination and you know just
deep in it and evolved from there right
so you'll get new locations you'll get
new missions you get new hits you'll get
live events for example imagine that all
the Hitman players in the world will
have 48 hours alive
you have to take this target out you
know and if the target target escapes
gone done right when one try one one hit
one shot one kill ride and the way you
kill the target that's the way the
target is killed up period let's talk
about some of the footage and we're
seeing here I it's all like an NBC or so
look like an Irish flag on top haha iris
right yeah very cool what are we looking
at here it looks that sort of hitman
there's always been a fashion a sort of
a very like almost European Flair right
hitman tell us about what we're looking
at here we need we love to go to
different exotic locations and this is
one of many this is Paris we here at a
fashion show there is this evil
corporation covering this up as a
fashion show but there's really more
shady things going on underneath says I
always knew it yeah fashions efficient
exactly always like that right so this
this target here is a Nava curve and you
have to infiltrate come in and
understand you know so how can you take
this guy out right he's protected at all
times and this is also the core
experience of hitman right so we
reintroduced some of the things that our
fans love yeah you know and there's a
loadout very advanced load out there is
a stash point so before you actually
enter yes enter the the location you can
strategize and you can put you know a
sniper gun a specific place where it can
when you coming to the location into the
location you can you can you know pick
it up later and use it for a
orchestrated assassination right so
there are deep sandbox this is the
biggest sandbox you know without
checkpoints this is biggest high density
ten boxes we've ever done so we're
looking at compared to the biggest
levels and absolution we'll look at that
six seven times bigger and also bigger
than the the Blood Money levels we've
done before but this this is it this is
the ultimate assassin experience yeah
well I guess you guys are Oh the
ultimate assassin explain I guess in
many ways hip man's been around for a
long time and Assassin's Creed has tried
to sort of you sir Pitt that's fair
series not having the moat the most
popular time at the moment so maybe you
guys can
I love the assassin assassin series so
this is this is the ultimate assassin
experience hitman accessible experience
that we see right here really confident
and happy with what we have one of the
difficult things to balance in a game
like this is that in those early hitman
games a one and two and when you got
caught you really had to just try and
hide in that I'm trying like attack from
a different angle and in some other
games and I guess when people change
difficulty levels there's a this
temptation to try and shoot your head of
a problem oh yeah I had a temptation how
are you guys like dealing with that we
play with that yeah obviously that's a
part of its a freedom of choice deeper
deep sandbox we're doing it's even more
now and obviously we want to choose you
all right you have the option to go in
and do a brutal assassination and try to
get away with that you know guns blazing
and everything you can also orchestrate
this you know this this was the brutal
one who saw their right and here you
have a more you know more ellicott
elegant assassination there I would
poison on so of course we do that we do
place you know security room shotguns
lying there with some shells and you
know that when the player comes there's
like I would really like to write so we
do a we do play with the temptation yeah
but it's really you know all the
opportunities are there so up to you how
are you play it you know sand assassin
stick around and make these very elegant
assassinations or just comes placing
it's up to you yeah one of the m at
great things about the hemline franchise
is being able to go back and replay
levels I always loved the first time
seeing a level because I kind of felt
like I was scoping an air or I was like
doing a bit of reconnaissance and then
on my fifth or sixth attempt that
actually I'd nail it I'd get in without
anyone seeing get the target and I get
out as quick as possible and hopefully
no one finds any sleeping guards and are
you guys taking a similar approach do
you kind of do you know that when people
play the game that they're going to go
into each level kind of blind and that
they'll they'll learn as they pick
through it totally I mean this is a very
nonlinear game right coming in there are
so many options so many directions like
so many rooms so many embassies with
different purposes so obviously that's
very very
Horton walk around try to understand
what this target is doing and this NBC's
are doing how can I use them to get
close to the target right and said
before the the systemic part is a lot
deeper I mean you can you know there's a
frisk you soon you can as an example as
a fiscal shown you can't get into the
area right but you could just throw your
gun on the street and just you know go
back back a bit and hide a bit you'll
see the police will come and look at it
as a gun here all right i'll pick it up
and then we'll look around and then they
will secure the gun obviously so they
will check that with them into the
building into a secure room and hide it
there and then you can get through this
frisking the fiscal zone right and you
know you don't have any guns on you find
a way to get into the room get your gun
and you know take the target out that
way so are all these systems going on
and it's really really fun to play
around and obviously you're taking a
sort of chaptered approach to it yeah
but we hear that Diana burn was
returning and in this game as well and I
guess my first question is is this a
sequel to absolution because no spoilers
for anyone who's played that and/or and
also how much does story play in a game
that you're going to be releasing over
the course of you know a year or so so
this this the story here is after after
absolution but but really I mean 1847 is
timeless right so absolution was very
storage driven whereas hitman is very
hit driven so it's a it's really back to
the core experience back to the roots so
the really important part is that the
hits they're really really rich and the
stories around around them in the
locations are really weird but there's
no walking story that connects these two
hits and drives the story right and that
story will be concluded during 2060 it's
exciting i like the idea of us getting
to play hitman over the course of a year
yeah I have to ask you just Ave Maria
turn up at any stage your invite it
might I got a couple of more questions
here obviously this is based on the air
the glacier 2 engine which is why you
guys use for absolution and did you find
porting that on to the next generation
console
like sort of scrubbing it up keeping up
with technology and did it allow you to
scale up in the right way of course yeah
I mean technologies are part of a DNA
we've been doing that from from day one
hit no one's exactly like I remember
walking in and out of like flags and
watching the stuff move exactly so so
this is the next generation of glacier
that supports it man and you know just
to just to give an idea where we're
cable a few where we have the graphical
fidelity from from absolution and the
big sandbox is from from blood money we
took that to another level right and so
also going digital adding a content
later being able to adjust features
mechanics content together with the
community in the gamers with their input
I mean all that is enabled by the new
functionalities and the higher fidelity
engine we have today and so december 8th
is when it's coming out it's not gonna
be on playstation 4 xbox one and pc as
well and the pc as well yeah so the
experience gonna start in december the
eighth and just gonna continue on of all
through throughout 2060 is there gonna
be a full price game at that stage and
then and then you'll keep adding on to
it as well exactly not like somewhat but
early access situation where you're a
started early access everything that
comes out from the IO Interactive it's
very important to say this this is its
final quality right it's finished game
so everything will release its going to
be finished and high quality obviously
that experience is just gonna evolve
right so the last location on missions
right now would be will be shaped by
what we learn and you know from how the
game is going to play this game and
that's a huge opportunity for us right
so now we don't just you know put the
baby in a box and that's it right we
actually have another tunity to tuned
experience and make it better for the
gamers i'm sure you can say now how much
but are you guys committing to like a
road map for that year is there like by
the time the game comes out will you be
saying there will be you know six or
eight or three years there will be lots
more information about that when we come
closer to the december the 8th right but
it's very important to say this is
everything here all this experience we
get for 60 bucks there will be no hidden
costs no microtransactions or anything
for 60 bucks you get the full experience
starting from December the 8th
throughout 2016 and a little bit
something extra for PlayStation 4 users
as well tell us about that yeah so so we
have a beta coming up we'll come with
more details with that or also a great
opportunity to get feedback before
before the launch of the game right so
really excited about that and looking
forward to that really happy with the
collaboration with the sony on that yeah
also there will be exclusive contracts
you know good story and some special
hits around that for for for the sony
platform so are they are they exclusive
contracts within levels already exist in
the game or what they've been like new
levels oh that would be a w combination
but uh but yeah there will be a part of
the huge locations that they will be
releasing right that's a big part of the
game right that's the globe-trotting
fantasy traveling around the world and
visiting fashionable Paris the Marrakech
and sorry yeah are you guys at all
working with the movie guys because this
is like the second hitman movie like
when the first one came out and Timothy
Olyphant was was playing agent 47 and it
almost seemed like just a really I don't
know it felt like a PC like everyone
loved that game and nurtured it never
felt like a massive block boss it grew
into a massive block west yeah but it
seems so incredibly odd that there was a
movie it must have been successful
because there's another movie yeah you
guys working with them at all I mean
obviously we have have some
collaborations with them like creative
color you know you know telling them
about the universe and agent 47 right
but you know we are game makers we are
not moving makers so but we're really
happy with the guys and doing a great
job we also really looking forward to to
watch a movie when it comes out I'm sure
to send you a DVD Wow so am I even on
DVD maybe something higher affinity soul
yeah 480p stream and so you've had
obviously had a massive showing here at
e3 last question when are you guys going
to be dropping details about the rest of
this game because we haven't really seen
anything in terms of like actual full
game player you guys going to be showing
stuff at Gamescom when we can actually
see the new hitman in action there will
be more
information soon and games graham is
most likely will be there as well that
that's that's what I can say right now
there will be more information and also
about the beta up to disseminate cool i
can smile interactive thank you so much
for your time really appreciated a very
much looking forward to seeing more of
agent 47 i will be back on the game
spots agent just a minute slime bunch of
cool stuff coming up and nikki was
coming on to talk about muddy number
nine tony hawk's gonna be on the stage
later but our boys from the UK jamie
jackson is on next to talk about guitar
here alive stick around be back in a
minute
[Music]